tonight from confronting coronavirus to
raising standards and securing funding
there are huge challenges facing our
schools teachers are under pressure
students underperforming screens are
taking over and now there are even
problem parents to deal with
you've got the questions now let's get
you some answers welcome to Q&A
[Music]
hi there good evening Julius tonight she
left atop Melbourne Grammar School to
finish her studies in the public system
year 12 student V Tron
here's career spans five decades and he
doesn't mind putting parents back in
their box school principal John Collier
he's been called the Kim Kardashian of
maths teaching yeah yep apparently
travelled here on the bus with his
students tonight at Eddie whoo Dux of
her school and a self-described
nerd Shadow Minister for education Tanya
Plibersek and he's gone from handing out
funding to schools as a Nationals
minister to advising how it should be
spent director of the Gonski Institute
Adrian piccoli please make them all feel
welcome
putting this on IP and YouTube and join
it on Facebook Twitter and the Graham
Condor is the hashtag please wash your
hands before you touch any devices our
first question tonight comes from Harry
Sita recently we've seen a number of
schools shut down for a day in response
to the current virus threat allowing
time for a containment strategy to come
into place now if in the coming weeks if
the situation worsens do you think our
high schools are prepared with the
knowledge and resources to facilitate
online learning for as long as it's
epidemic lasts and how might this affect
your 12 students down the line during
trials if physical exams at the time out
of the question
Eddie Wu or any of your students
panicking yet
I wouldn't say panicking we're really
grateful to have fantastic support
around us that means even though we know
this is in some ways for this generation
of students quite unprecedented Harry it
wasn't that long ago that you're in
chair technology high school and you
know and thankfully we have a lot of
great support underneath any student who
is away even you know coronaviruses
aside when they're representing the
school when they're engaged in different
excursions that's one of the great
reasons why technology is powerful but
are you telling students that are in
their final year that they have to be
realistic maybe things will be disrupted
disruptions already begun I don't live
that far from Epping boys which of
course was closed for a short amount of
time so we know that there's real
disruption of course and to be fair this
is something which is not new just the
scale of it is a little bit different
when I was going through my HSC my mom
was going through her final year of life
fighting with lung cancer that was
pretty disruptive to what's really
important is that for each of the
different cohorts for each student we're
providing things like technology to
support the loan that's happening and
what's really important for every edge
assistant here to remember is that while
of course there are really important
stakes this is one milestone among many
and that continued learning more so than
what happens in one particular final
exam that's the part that matters the
you worry to your friends worked um
personally I think that we should be
putting students health at first
obviously but I am a bit worried with
obviously how is it going to logistical
II happen and if schools don't actually
have the technology or the funding to
actually fund online learning then
what's going to happen to
schools and we definitely need to
consider different ways to actually
support them John I know you said to me
that there's a range of views within
your school about how acutely this needs
to be dealt with there is a range some
people are quite concerned some aren't
concerned at all scores like mine I'm
sure all schools are trying to be
responsible to keep up-to-date with the
health warnings to be agile but not to
overreact so in my school we have a
crisis team we're actually meeting again
tomorrow morning and we're testing our
IT systems because we expect we mainly
to do online delivery and if that
happens I think that curriculum
authorities will need to look at what
latitude they can give to actually put
the images of students first because
that's what schools are about we're
about looking after our students so we
will get through this but there may be
some disruption along the way and
schools will deal with that as best as
they can while looking after their
students so the chief medical officer
says they're looking at this 14-day
isolation period is that duration
present schools particularly with a
problem it is a long period of time and
no clear indication to whether it's
actually the right length yes there's no
clear indication and because coronavirus
is obviously a novel virus it's new
we're responding to the medical
situation as that develops we had a
pediatrician in today speaking to our
senior students and the medical
profession too is trying to cope with it
is to learn as it goes along so I think
it's important to be agile and to
support our students as best we can all
right our next question tonight is a
video question from Emma Ritchie in
Clayton Victoria my name is Emma
I am a teacher and I and many others I
learn have been threatened and abused by
students and parents I've read
repeatedly in the media that it is the
teachers fault this lowered student
outcomes while we stay up late marking
and preparing engaging lessons for the
kids we also regularly have our have
people domain our job and teachers are
leaving the profession in large numbers
do you think that teachers will function
better and students will achieve better
outcomes if teachers feel safe supported
and respected at work john collier there
can only be one answer to that question
and it is that if teachers are supported
and valued of course they'll do better
because they're human beings and this is
true in all occupations and so we need
to change the narrative about schools in
our society we actually have world-class
schools in Australia
they're called government schools
they're called Catholic schools they're
called independent schools their schools
and other systems we know we have
world-class schools because our best
education academics tell us sir and I'm
talking about people like John Hattie
best known international education
academic and it doesn't do any good for
the media and sometimes politicians to
lash schools and pretend that schools
are the reason for all of society's ills
teachers
and I just want to pick up on the point
though that Emma made about the abuse
that teachers received because you sent
a newsletter to your school community in
2018 and this is what you said you said
that you're having to interact with too
many parents who have verbally abused
physically threatened or shouted at a
staff member you went on to say I'm
aware some parents because they're
paying fees see the relationship with
teachers as a master-servant
relationship such that they are entitled
to make extravagant demands why did you
do that I did that ironically because at
San Andres Cathedral School is hardly
any problem at all with pills and I
wanted to keep it that way and so I got
onto the front foot and to my
astonishment my newsletter to these six
to eight parents only in my school who
were troublesome after one month went
viral internationally so it seemed to
strike a chord
not just with schools and not just with
independent schools but with government
school principals with local council
staff with health workers who gave me
lots of feedback about the disappearance
of much of the civility in society and I
take that to mean that we have a society
which has stress and where people think
it's satisfactory to lash out at ups and
I was in effect standing against that
and I got thanks from France Brazil New
Zealand so it seems to be an
international issue particularly across
the Western world where people are
responding in a sway and I want to say
quite clearly that teachers should not
be the target I've been teaching for
forty-eight years I've been a principal
for thirty the number of teachers in any
school government or independent that
I've seen that aren't trying their
hardest over nearly 50 years I would
count on the fingers of one hand okay it
is not satisfactory to attack teachers
because the firings are societal they're
not essentially educational tenure sec
problem parents have you seen them are
you one
well you'd have to ask my kids teachers
whether I am I know I'll answer in two
ways as a parent I think it's really
important to back teachers and I've got
three kids they're all very different
and I do occasionally get a note home
about the behavior of one or more of my
children and I don't ring the teacher
and say you're so wrong you don't
understand my child's brilliance so you
know I say can you do that I know and
it's complete I think that's wrong I
think you should be reinforcing the
standards that the school sets for
school behavior at school at home with
your kids but what your question it was
asking about was even one step beyond
that people who are verbally and
physically abusive never on never okay
absolutely 100% not but I think it goes
to another question as well a lot of
teachers particularly at the beginning
of their careers say that they don't
feel well prepared for dealing with kids
with behavioral issues in their
classroom or kids with special learning
needs in their classroom and I think
making sure that our initial teacher
training is strong in that area and that
early career teachers have a lot of
support if they've got kids with
behavioral issues in their classrooms is
so important as well it's important for
the kids learning and it's important for
the teacher and keeping those teachers
in the classroom coming on this tiny
I want to bring in Dorothy hot-or-not
here because she was the principal of
Holroyd high school for 23 years I think
Dorothy what do you make having runner
school
John collee is approached telling the
parents right this is too much get back
in the box
I don't think that was an issue in a
school like Holroyd which was a
disadvantaged school where a lot of the
parents didn't have any agency anyway in
society or in their children's education
a lot of our parents couldn't speak
English and a lot of our parents because
they were refugees didn't have very much
education themselves as I said that's a
basic issue for a lot of schools that
that your parents can't really engage in
a in a powerful way with their
children's education because they have
may have had little education themselves
and they're also quite fearful and and
respectful of the school in one sense so
where does this sense of entitlement
about how the school behaves come from
well I I don't know which school are you
talking about well I think it depends
very much I there were there were times
when I was very glad that we didn't have
many middle-class parents in the school
I think we also caught that look school
principal of 23 years V I want to get
your take on this because you and your
family have a particular view of how
Australia treats teachers yes I both my
parents are Vietnamese refugees and
especially my father he came when he was
my age which was 1718 and he went
through life and death situations to
actually get to Australia UK man apart
yeah he was a very refugee and he and my
mother grew up with poverty especially
in Vietnam and especially just learning
in Australia first go and so they
understood that education was a way to
actually move past socio-economic
disparities and actually build yourself
up from poverty so I've really grown up
with a respect for education because I
know that in a lot of countries in the
world and especially
developing countries they don't have the
same opportunities that we do in
Australia and we need to stop taking it
for granted and actually start realizing
that yes there are flaws and we need to
reform it and it has the potential to be
a great world class system but I think
that it really does have to come down to
how students view teachers how teachers
themselves view themselves and also how
society views teachers I do think that
students do need to respect the the
education system I think that if you
don't respect them and you don't engage
with the system then you're not actually
learning from it and we're so lucky to
be in a country like Australia which we
are offered education and obviously it's
not perfect but at least we are fit
education and an opportunity to go to
university there's a lot of like my
parents in Vietnam you don't there's
certainly so many people that actually
get into university and it's a tough
competition there and in a lot of
countries and I think also teachers also
need to be able to see are they engaged
and are they passionate and are they
respecting also the student and not I'm
encouraging them to potentially
participate in discussions or raise
questions and obviously not push them to
the side and say you're just a kid you
don't know anything because maybe they
have something valuable to actually say
and I think we just need to work on
respect in the education system not just
from one demographic but as a whole in
society
[Music]
is that something that through policy
you can change human behavior is very
difficult to change through government
policy but what we're seeing but but
what we're seeing really in school is
the reflection what's happening in the
other part come on we talk about this
every week on Q&A people come and turn
up young people particularly and say
look at what our politicians do in
Parliament oh look at the way they
shouted it go to weekend sport and have
a look at how the referees talk to
listen to talkback radio listen to the
way they talk to people
ring Twitter I don't turn it off turn it
off right because I mean this is a
social ill there's not a school Hill
there's no class for being a jerk in in
school ain't kids and parents are
bringing this into the school and
they're learning the outside this school
I guess right no way should teachers
have to put up with that no-one should
put up with that in the work in the
workplace for a start and I'd say if I
was still the Minister of educators say
no when Sir when it's appropriate call
the cops
get the police involved cuz no one in
the workplace and no one actually ever
deserves to put up with that kind of
behavior and there should be absolutely
zero tolerance to it but part of this is
the hyper-competitiveness now in schools
right you know I my kid needs this in
order to get that edge in there in year
12 or whatever it is is
hyper-competitiveness throughout our
society in our culture schools and
example sports another example do
parents expect too much of the school I
know you have an issue with the amount
of screen time kids you have and the
impact that has on them in the classroom
is your message in part to parents
you've actually got to do more
yeah as a parent of a 9 year old in a 12
year old you know I'm afraid of what
consequences there are for my children
and and screens and we've pretty strict
my parent my kids are not great fans of
me cuz we're really strict I mean good
day I'm worried about I think we have
the same knowledge about impacts of
screens as we had about cigarette
smoking in the 30s you know are we gonna
look back in 50 years time and say hey
you know there are three year olds
sitting in prams with with screens
imagine doing that the same way we look
at back at our attitudes towards making
the Marlboro Man was
well today Apple is cool are we gonna
are we gonna say and I've been in a few
decades time look at the mental health
consequences I mean they are significant
we're doing some work at UNSW through
the Gonski Institute around screen time
and impacts that's happening having with
some Canadian and researchers from
Harvard about this correlation between
all these mental health consequences and
social consequences and the rise in in
screen use and I gotta say you know more
work needs to be done but it's it's not
looking good we don't know the
ramifications it's having it's having
you know changing children's minds
changing their the way their brains
operate and I think the consequences are
really serious and a lot more work needs
to be done all right next question
tonight comes from Finn McBride hi I'm a
u12 student at an independent boys
school I've witnessed firsthand how a
dangerous culture of sexism and misogyny
can easily be promoted amongst students
boys at same-sex schools being prepared
enough for the world outside year 12 and
what can I be doing as a student to be a
better Ally for women Finn McCready with
that question I made up the surname V
what's your view on that
is there this sort of toxic masculinity
that we hear about that we've seen in in
the news yeah I definitely think that
there is a culture of toxic masculinity
and I think one of the problems we have
is that we give them this justification
of our boys will be boys you know like
that's just how they are but we have to
understand that the actions that arise
are not acceptable and it's not just
about your gender but it's about
actually sometimes the crimes that they
commit so I'm so tired of hearing you
know it's just like just let them be
they'll grow up but if we don't teach
them now whether what they're doing is
wrong then we can't actually tackle the
problem when they all go out into the
workplace and possibly contribute to
workplace harassment I know you know in
the news that we see obviously in the
recent case with the tram chance that
these usually private school boys they
feel like that they have the confidence
and that they feel they have the courage
or that's a positive word but they have
this audacity to say such things in
public
and then we see numerous incidences of
sexual assault and sexual harassment of
schoolboys showing you know their
friends nudes without the girls actual
consent or that they're taking pictures
of girls skirts and we have to
understand that it's not okay and I know
that I'm lucky in lucky to have not
faced that direct sexual harassment or
assault but there shouldn't be a lucky
one there shouldn't be a fortunate
person a woman shouldn't have to feel
like they're unsafe in their own school
environment and I shouldn't have to sit
in a class or sit with my peers and
think there is a girl here that has been
sexually harassed or even assaulted and
we need to start holding these students
in countable and also we need to stop
thinking that what we're doing currently
is enough because we see after the
incident and after incident that what
we're doing isn't enough
I think suspensions personally you know
on paper to the school it might look
like a serious consequence but actually
try and think it back to the victim or
to the perpetrator to the perpetrator
potentially a few days of school is you
know hooray
I get school off days off school and you
know I'll just move on from that and
I'll just live my life and not actually
learn my lesson and then the victim
sitting there you know being traumatized
and is gonna impact their entire life
and they're thinking how can how can
they just get away with it and we need
to start holding not only schools but
also students accountable for the
actions and consequences that they
impact upon students
accountability for public schools but
you want greater accountability for the
private schools which receive public
funding explain yeah I think you know
there's this whole argument about
funding and we're gonna get to that yeah
but but I do think that public schools
are held did I treated differently to
non-government schools particularly
around this issue of account of
accountability I mean public schools
have to record critical incidents
non-government schools record them but
they're not necessarily made made public
whereas in public schools they they
certainly are and I think in exchange
for public funding any school against
public funding whether they be a public
school a Catholic school or independent
school should be under those same rules
of accountability and transparency
including how the money how the money is
allocated even to non-government schools
particularly within non-government
school systems come in on that one
sure pick up though on that because I
noted you had mentioned the paperwork
that the Catholic school system had to
comply with in order to get 800 million
dollars worth of funding from your state
when you were the Education Minister how
much paperwork did they have to do that
was it was one page the page at what I
saw when asked the Department for brief
was it was one page now now for a six
hundred million dollar check that's not
enough if you apply for a thirty
thousand dollar grant for Scouts yeah do
a lot more than that so it wasn't about
accusing anybody of doing the wrong
thing but the accountability in the
transparency needs to be equal that way
you don't see that the incidents well
less chance of seeing the incidents like
we saw in in Melbourne where where
things can happen in some schools but
there's no transparency around and
unless police get involved wrong or
somebody finds out about it John Collier
I don't think it's true that there's a
lack of accountability in independent
schools in fact we are overwhelmed with
accountability we're tied up in red tape
and compliance and I spent much of my
time as do my finance people in India
in school the quicking reports the
government there about a whole raft of
things student welfare curriculum
examinations funding we report to Nessa
in New South Wales we report to the
state government we report to the
federal government it's simply not the
case that we are unaccountable we are
massively accountable and I have no
problem with accountability my issue is
whether all of the raft of paperwork
which takes teachers away from their
primary task of teaching is actually
necessary and justified and this is a
broader issue than what we're discussing
right now because the accountability and
compliance requirements affect teachers
in all sectors and actually take them
away from the frontline tasks of
teaching and pastoring students because
I'm not sure that the benefit from that
is proportional to the amount of time
spent we go back to Finn's question just
for a second because he asked two things
so what can we do to change this culture
and I think we have had some really
effective respectful relationships
programs in schools I don't think
they're widespread enough it's now in
the curriculum but I reckon if there's
young people in the audience how many of
you feel like you've had effective
respectful relationships education so
far at school yeah like not a hands
going up for this video those and and so
I do think from a very early age there
are great models that teach people about
you know age appropriate how to
negotiate respectful relationships how
to have healthy friendships as time goes
on how to have healthy sexual
relationships as well we need to do
better I know that the teachers will say
I've got one more thing in the
curriculum I get that but this is so
fundamental if it's only being taught at
home at school and what you're seeing at
home is completely contrary to that then
what happens at school isn't going to
counteract that so we have to go well
beyond what's happening in schools to
what's happening in families society
community
Adrian was talking about before sporting
organisations politicians have to lead
as well to say that violence and sex
sysm are never okay not ever not in any
context ever but you said you also said
what can you do to be a better Ally I
think the fact you've asked the question
has kind of answered that you obviously
already are but but I do have a message
for young men like quite often you will
be in a group and things could go one
way or the other you know someone's
vulnerable someone's on their own
someone's about to be bullied someone's
about to be assaulted harassed you have
to be the leader in that group and it's
hard it's embarrassing people think you
you you know straighting 180 whatever be
that leader and and that culture change
that you do amongst your peers is so
much more powerful than me talking about
on television or your teachers or your
pair
all right our next question tonight
comes from Jim alchun culture and
tradition a key aspects of sin Joseph's
College the school that I attend how do
we ensure that strong traditions stay
intact without a backwards culture
developing in our schools
okay anyway I want to put this to you
because you work in the public system
but you are of Christian faith strongly
of Christian faith what do you think is
the value of tradition and faith in the
education system hmm the tradition of
faith have immense value and I think is
a wonderful thing that we have diversity
within the Australian school system I
think it's one of the great things that
we can prize in the week and treasure
you spoke before about the OP the the
sort of worried about being backwards
whilst praising tradition and I think
it's while it's not easy to do
it's easy to identify how to avoid that
problem and that's to say why did these
traditions come about why why does my
faith which is ancient centuries old
what does it actually stand for as
opposed to things that we say things
that we follow patterns and rituals that
we kind of have lost the meaning of I
mean there are modern examples of this
as well I'm delighted for example that
now as opposed to when I was at school
it's a standard practice in a New South
Wales public school to have an
acknowledgement of country when you
can't have a welcome to country
are too long in waiting to bring that
about but at the same time and I've seen
it dozens scores or times that that
itself even though it is a newer
recognized thing simply becomes a script
that we read off and even though it's
not old within our schools it's become
that same backward-looking doesn't have
a sense of the meaning of why it's
important that we've recognized the
traditional custodians of the land so I
think it's about fastening on the
meaning of the things that we do and
sometimes that means you have to shatter
something old that is lost that mean
because culture and society are moving
in that way and it takes courage to ask
those questions like I did Eddie some of
the problems that have been described by
both Adrian and Tanner to do with
society as a whole
drifting away from principles I mean is
that something in your view that faith
can play a role in within the education
system this is a really interesting
question to have host to me because as a
public school teacher in the mantra of
public education is it as free
compulsory and secular but at the same
time one of the great things about its
secularity is that it makes room for
people of all faiths of all belief
systems of all convictions so one of the
things that I think really matters is
that we look at all those different
individuals all the different cultures
that make Australia a beautiful place
and we can't deny that I know there's
been a big conversation around
multiculturalism when I was you know at
school when I was your age this is a
conversation which I felt very ill
equipped to actually have compared to
today we need to be able to make space
for that conversation to happen this
comes back to Finn's question before
sexism racism like I faced when I was
younger this is something which is at
the heart of every single human being
it's not new and it's not something
which we've moved on from every
generation needs to learn afresh how to
give respect so those are different
cultures those of different identities
this is something that Australia as a
whole doesn't have an answer to and
perhaps the themes that he's talking
about it playing out more broadly the
the contest between tradition and
adapting culturally I think the best
schools have a respect for a tradition
but presents an eclectic mix of
time-honored educational success and the
best of current research and that seems
to me to be the way to go and I could be
talking about an independent school the
way it is just talked about the
government sector that is to say most
independent schools are not on clothes
they represent the same microcosm of
society with the same diversity and even
though they may have a particular faith
commitment they shall respect for other
commitments and no faith commitment that
certainly a description of my school
where it is multicultural
and one of the best things that was said
to me last year by the party year 12
students he came across the stage is
thinking you so very much for making me
a Muslim welcome for these six years in
the st. in school and I was delighted to
hear that because that's the kind of
inclusive approach we need in a
multicultural multi-faith society where
we express respect how important is
discipline discipline is very important
because where that discipline we can't
have order and with that order we can't
have proper focus on teaching and
learning and that's what teachers do and
that's what schools are essentially
about so it matters I think that yes
there should be a respect towards you
know the system and discipline but I
also think that that can have potential
to be abused and I think that it's
sometimes you have to think okay a
teacher might be right but there are
still human and they might be wrong and
we have seen cases where teachers have
abused students or you know
administration has not listened to
students so I think that while we do
have a respect for discipline and we do
have to respect kind of or
and hierarchy in institutions like
schools that we still engage and listen
with the students because they are
ultimately the ones who are impacted the
most by this discipline and by rules and
perhaps they have something to give to
the table and that they actually have a
genuine experience that might impact the
way that you look to discipline students
you're on the on the verge of adulthood
right and a big part of your education
till now has been to teach you to tell
the difference between right and wrong
your education at home in your education
at school and I think I think you could
answer your own question when you're
confronted with a problem we see some
very positive traditions that bind
groups together in a way that is
inclusive and healthy and we see some
very negative ones you only need to look
at the hazing rituals at some of the
colleges at universities that leave
people drunk or in hospital or sexually
assaulted or whatever else to know that
that's a tradition but it's not one that
anyone should be continuing I think I
think equipping people to make their own
decisions about what our positive
rituals or values in an organization and
what you should be fighting to change is
a really important part of Education all
right our next question tonight comes
from Jing Chou my question is for mr.
edu and when my children moved to see me
from Shanghai in January 2019 they were
disappointed to find out that class math
was one or two years behind what they
learned in Shanghai so what do you think
needs to be done in Australia to improve
the standard of math teachings Eddie
Wu that chimes pretty neatly with the
Pisa result findings the program for
international school assessment which
showed Australian students are now more
than three and a half years behind these
their Chinese peers when it comes to
Tomas hmm how much time do you have
Josiah there are so many differences
between obviously the Australian
education
system as a whole and what's happening
in Shanghai and you know your reference
to Pez results Hamish is also telling
because this has been something which
we've tracked year on your own year
every you know three or four years when
this comes out we've seen a fairly
consistent trend and it's absolutely
concerning action has to be taken and
it's really important to note that and
there's a huge difference this is going
to the conversation we had before about
the culture of schools in the place of
education in Australia as opposed to a
place like Shanghai for example when I
go to school and when I teach the number
of hours that I actually spend
face-to-face with my students versus the
number of hours that our teacher from
Shanghai spends face-to-face their
students focused on teaching learning
vastly different and there's also a huge
difference in when we have a look at the
numbers on who's actually standing in
front of classrooms I got a mathematics
degree when I went to train to become a
teacher and that makes me really
fortunate to have the opportunity like
they was talking about as someone who
his parents came to this country so I
could have that opportunity but it's
pretty clear the desire that doesn't
make any sort of illusion about this
that not every student around Australia
gets that same experience when we have a
look in high schools where we need
special stitches as opposed to in
primary where we have generalists on
average we actually have only about 60%
of our students from year 7 to 10 with a
teacher as a maths degree who is
qualified and has more than just a
willingness to teach that subject
someone who has trained to become a math
teacher over their time they're now 60%
sounds like a pretty low number it is
but it actually gets worse than that
because that's over four years so I'm a
balling this you know let's say about
200 people here in this room so you're
you seven tonight all of you 120 of you
putting the line about here everyone to
this side 120 of you get the maths
teacher in year 7 good for you that's
nice for you seven but then that happens
again in your eighth only 60% of that
group and then by year nine 60% of that
group by the end of year 10 after four
years there's only gonna be doing
numbers live on it that's a bad idea
it's only gonna be
27 students in the room who had a maths
teacher all the way through those 4
years why are we surprised that by the
time students hit 15 which is when
they're assessed on Pisa they're right
in the thick of experiencing either
fantastic mathematics teaching all that
way
or an interrupted experience of that
that accounts for a lot of the
differences that we see within systems
Adrienne P Kelly over a decade and a
half it's clear the trajectory is down
when it comes to math specifically at
the same time we've had all of these
reforms the Gonski reforms both versions
what have we done wrong well I think
it's important to say that we we still
have a very good education system in
Australia I mean we do it's right to
focus on what needs to be improved but I
think it's always important to say the
things that we do right we know how to
deliver a world-class education to
students in Australia and we do just not
as Eddie said not to every student and
that's the problem you drive it but the
line goes directly down yeah it's been
going down for about 16 years
yep according to the Pisa results at the
same time as all of these reforms that
are supposed to make the system better
yep and which have brought about more
funding than ever before yeah but the
interesting trend also is that it's
every state is training the same way
every sector government Catholic
independent are trending the same way
across just about every demographic I
mean high-performing students are
performing worse low performing students
are performing worse I mean the trend is
uniform when you look at those Pisa
results in it in detail the trend is
uniform which actually says to me there
is something more cultural national
going on here in terms of our
performance because different states
different things different sectors do
different things you might actually
think that the trend would be a little
bit different one will be going up when
we go down that all training in the same
direction
can I ask you though because when you
were the Education Minister in New South
Wales you made some really significant
cuts I think it was 2012 1.7 billion
dollars worth of cuts total of 1,800
jobs were cars do you look at that
decision now and think well yeah that's
why we've ended up with this
results are looking a nice try
sufen you must reflect on some of those
decisions and ask if part of that is
causing this ah look no not at all I
mean we made the decisions we had to
make at the time and and actually we
then had the opportunity to actually put
it all back plus more when we invested
or when we co invested with the
Commonwealth in Gonski funding so New
South Wales schools all sectors
government independent Catholic are far
better off funding wise now than they
were eight years ago when when all of
this happened so that if you take 200
million dollars out of public schooling
as you did well we did we it has impacts
we did we did it we did it it's it's all
none of it was inside the school gate
right none of it was inside the school
gate but then what we were able to do as
a result of the things that we did
around you know reducing the bureaucracy
etc we're actually able to co-invest
with the Commonwealth on a two-thirds
one-third basis we put in a third con
well put in two thirds and all school
sectors in New South Wales and now are
substantially better off than they were
eight years ago now had we not done that
we wouldn't have been able to afford to
do make those kinds of investments but
all parts of the New South Wales
government at the time made those
savings so that we actually could invest
it in education which is what we did can
I jump in on the funding question um New
South Wales was the first state to sign
up to the Gonski reforms and what
happened after that you're talking about
the original way original introduced by
back in the good old days yeah what
happened in 2014 in that first horror
budget of Tony Abbott's and joi hockey's
was that the signed agreements that all
of this most of the states and
territories had with the Commonwealth
were thrown out the window and 30
billion dollars of future funding was
taken out of Education so it's you know
by all means give Adrian a hard time
tonight but it is telling that the
federal Education Minister isn't here
tonight
to answer the same question about the
massive federal government cuts to
education can we be clear though what
you mean by federal government cuts
because you've been picked up on it a
number of times you went to the last
election claiming 14b
worth of cuts made by this government
they there was actually in comparison to
what you were promised yeah
no it's in comparison to what the states
and territories signed up for what they
were promised what not I don't care
about the government being promised it I
care about kids being promised it
schools were expecting but it was the
government on their own policy it was it
no I was opposed to what so it was at
the first cut in 2014 was thirty billion
dollars and that was the difference over
ten years between what the Liberals
funded schools and what they would have
got under the signed agreements and
arrangements that were already in place
under the former Labour government John
Collier I want to agree with any that
there are problems with appropriate
teacher supply and I want to partially
agree with Aiden and tenure what I want
to say you know they're from different
sides I want to talk about Pisa for a
moment and say that the results in
please are very stratified and a
simplistic analysis will not cut the
mustard for instance in Pisa the
independent schools in New South Wales
were respectively third in the world in
the AC the literacy tests fourth in
science and eighth in mathematics now
where is the problem the problem that we
have in Australia is essentially an
equity problem that is to say that
students who need support whether they
be in government schools or the poor are
cathegory independent schools are not
getting the government support that they
need and so funny
I need to be targeted just not just
looked at at a quantum further I'd say
we're asking the wrong question about
Pisa if people are saying education is
failing because there are some pleaser
school problems I'm saying you can't
measure education by a small sample test
of United students which doesn't
actually test the Australian raise the
question of equity and we've actually
got a ton of questions on equity tonight
from various students in our audience
we're gonna meet a couple of them just
now Ruby you're in u7 I can get round
right girls hide you at very small
sitting down so do you want to stand up
that'll make this easy yet you've seen
your own school but you've also seen
other schools and private schools how do
they compare well um my school it's
amazing but there's like a lot of
cosmetic issues there's the whole school
is made of concrete and it's just bare
exposed concrete there's a lot of the
classrooms ill-equipped for modern
learning and barely any of them have
aircon but I went to Scaggs and sorry I
wasn't meant to say Scaggs but this is a
private school you had to have a look
there how does it compare
it was incredible like the grounds were
huge and it was so beautiful and
everything was shiny
they even had like a life-size skeleton
with like organs and everything and I
just couldn't understand why schools
like that are getting funding over
schools like mine
before
I want to be the Prime Minister of
Australia would you like to set up as
well you've moved to Sydney from
Griffith in regional New South Wales
compare the schooling experience there
with the peace bank what stands out in
particular about the comparison in
private school schooling here and public
school schooling in rural New South
Wales is that there is a clear disparity
between the resources the facilities and
the outside of school educational
opportunities so for myself I was unable
to access debating competitions because
of the area I lived in and because of my
location and so for me that raises the
question of not why did I want to go to
a private school but rather how can I
further my educational opportunities and
it's things like being here tonight and
being able to be part of the discussion
and debate which proved that rural
students are not able to access these
things and despite what's being done in
terms of Gonski and Aurora College which
I know was Adrian's initiative there's
still no other rural students here and I
would like to see in the future so many
more who are able to attend and able to
have these educational opportunities
obviously a huge number questions on
this tonight you at the school captain
at Cheltenham Eloise what's your
question I'm sorry I go to a public
school and I see many non-government
schools that have Olympic sized indoor
swimming pools and world-class theaters
and baronial style libraries and I see
that they should they don't need public
funding but I still see them getting a
lot of resources and funding from the
government and at the same time I see
schools and public schools like my own
that are sometimes not able to give
basic learning resources like textbooks
because we simply do not have enough how
is this fair and why are we funding
privileged not educational outcomes
is this what the Gonski reforms were all
about
well the Gonski reforms were actually
about we're about needs-based funding so
their school's resourcing standard you
know it's quite technical but every
student gets funded based on on need and
then if you had a particular
characteristic a particular disadvantage
characteristic that there would be extra
funding and enough funding would go with
whichever school you went to so
needs-based funding delivers funding to
students who need it now there are
existing disparities around this school
resourcing standard who's above it who's
below it and they're all these
transition periods so you know it's it's
it's complicated but so the system has
gotten better
before you go although it's not fixed
because the Australian Curriculum
assessment and reporting Authority says
yeah actually that over the past decade
public funding to private schools has
risen nearly twice as fast as public
funding to public schools mm-hmm that's
not quite what you're saying well I mean
I'm not here to defend the Commonwealth
government either the current one or the
previous one right that's not my job
here the New South Wales government that
I was a part of we certainly did
increase the amount of money that we
spent on public schools and the reason
we signed up to Gonski particularly is
because when I saw the numbers as
Minister about which schools would
benefit the most the ones who benefited
the most were country schools regional
and remote schools huge beneficiaries
the second biggest beneficiaries were
Western and southwestern Sydney and the
ones who benefited the the the least
were the ones you would expect to
benefit the least that's why we signed
up for it that's why we took the
measures we took to make sure that we
could invest in it and I think there
look funding is not fixed by any stretch
of the imagination but it is much better
than it was 10 years ago and I've got to
say Simon Simon Birmingham and Malcolm
Turnbull fixed it again a little bit by
reducing somebody so kind of dog of 2.0
is that one yeah they reduced the
funding that was going the over funding
that was going to some non-government
school so you know I've got to give them
credit as well it's far from fixed but
it is the improvement
what it was can I just say we wanted to
jump in here it's just about the formula
though can I just add something to the
formula super quickly so sir audience
described the schooling resource
standard blah blah blah let's just call
that a schools fair funding level okay
what the Commonwealth government has now
done is said that every non-government
school by 2023 will get to a hundred
percent or more of their fair funding
level but public schools will only ever
get to 95% of their fair funding level
that's in the formula that's baked in
that that inequality is now baked in
based on the arrangements that the
Commonwealth government's made with the
states and territories that that's at
the heart of the unfairness so to be
specific how would you fix it how would
you change
well schools should get to a hundred
percent of this their fair funding
levels so where would you find the money
from well you have to do these things
over time you have to at the moment by
2023 every non-government school will be
at a hundred percent or more and no
public school will ever get there no
sorry ninety nine percent of public
schools will never get there under this
model and change the process through
which independent schools are adjust not
gonna I'm not going to make up a funding
model on TV on your show to shine do you
think you'd be familiar with the
argument about doing it based on
postcodes versus the actual income of
the parents that actually is irrelevant
to this I think that's a fair imagine
taking our parents actually income as a
fair measure but that's not the question
here the question is do we get all
schools to their fair funding level or
is it okay that public schools never get
there under this model so when you have
a policy for fixing that by the next
election well we've got two years till
the next election and at last our last
education policy had fourteen billion
dollars extra for public schools anybody
really briefly I just think it needs to
be added on to this conversation because
I think that we often get sort of caught
in the morass of funding and numbers and
just from that classroom teacher
perspective again and Adrian knows this
history he's wrong Griffith and when I
get the opportunity which is really a
privilege for me to work with teachers
in regional rural and remote air
is it really needs to be said that money
on its own doesn't fix the problem but
every scores resource allocation model
which is it's true if for very small
schools and for ones with
socio-educational disadvantage get this
extra loading but when you go out to
Griffith so those teachers who get given
lots of money for professional learning
they still can't access it for at least
two reasons number one they need to get
on a plane to come to Sydney or on
another metropolitan send to stay there
for a night then come back so actually
ironically we've we've seen this issue
with toilet paper recently for someone
like me who lives in the metro area it
is when you can get it so much cheaper
to actually access those kinds of
resources in the teaching space for
professional learning than someone in a
regional area and then there's the
second part which is that three-day
round trip there isn't a teacher in
Griffith to replace that person so just
needs to recognize there's a far more
complex picture than just throwing money
in different directions we need to
actually knuckle down and see how are we
going to address these issues at a
personal level John
I'm very sympathetic to the point of
view from the student from brand Rick
and the student from Cheltenham I'm a
working class boy by background I went
to government schools the students I
worked in public sector for 25 years so
I was a government school principal my
grandchildren go to government schools
my son in law teachers in the government
school my answer to this is that funding
needs to be sector blind needs based
that's what Godsey was supposed to be
the problem the problem is that Godsey
has been politicized tenure blames the
Abbott government I'm happy with that I
also blame the Gillard government
because you see I was there at the
original Gonski release when gonzaga is
four five billion dollars and the prime
minister said there's no more money and
so god's he was a forlorn figure from
the beginning with his legs cut from
under him and god's he didn't recognize
what god's be became there's a lot of
misunderstanding about funding in
federalism which is part of their
problem with the back passing between
states and federal the federal
government basically funds
non-government schools and the state
government basically funds government
schools that's confusing if we can
actually have needs-based funding
without special deals for interest
groups we will be a lot better off in
this society what do you mean by that I
mean that various lobby groups from
within education from particular sectors
can threaten governments that they will
campaign in margin electorates and this
can influence government policy can you
give us an example of that
well we all know the example because
it's in the public domain there is a
great deal of politicking by Catholic
education in Victoria before the last
federal election and the Catholic sector
is perhaps not as served to funds as the
mode of otherwise been and I think
that's in the public tonight and we need
to actually fund on the basis of need
and not on the basis of politics
what do you make of the the reasons the
explanations for this funding disparity
I think we're talking quite big so we're
talking about policies and legislations
but we have to listen to students and
the students here have definitely made a
great point and I've witnessed it myself
microbe is not a private school we are a
government school and we don't have over
also you don't have swimming pools and
we have collapsing ceilings and it's not
fair when I go to a debating competition
in really affluent school that has all
of these big ovals to the point where
they have a separate campus for their
sports facilities and then I look at
definitely there's other public schools
that are worse off than my crop where
they don't they go in mobile classrooms
with no air conditioning with no heating
their cramped they don't they can't even
run certain subjects because of the
amount of funding so why is there still
funding going to schools with Olympic
sized moving decks or they still have
all of these campuses when they don't
need funding and there's so many other
schools especially the students that
have raised their concerns they actually
need the funding so it's not about you
know the big obviously it's a big
picture but we have to look at you know
the certain schools that are actually
impacted and what students are saying is
they're not it's not enough to say oh
yeah we're doing enough when evidently
now it's not enough that there are
schools who are suffering there are
schools that are obviously doing well
because of how much funding they're
getting and you see it in everywhere so
for example in debating in Div we see a
lot of the top kind of private oh boy
schools really dominating the rankings
and a lot of the time it's because they
can afford these adjudicators and these
coaches that can train them and give
them resources and their schools can
supply actual classrooms to debate in
and then public schools are actually
left without any of that and come up
against you yet
well it's just unfair to see just
schools doing well because they were
lucky enough to be born in an affluent
family and the government needs to take
care of students actually going to
public schools which is the majority and
see how we can help them instead of just
prioritizing the rich minority
disclaimer I would love in my
independent school st. Andrew's
Cathedral school to have a swimming pool
or a naval we don't have those things we
don't have a tree line drive we don't
have a drive we don't have a tree so
just bear in mind that the average
independent school in Australia is
mottle wealthy school most independent
schools in Australia have an SES of a
hundred and three or less and so the
schools that we're talking about at the
top 1% of independent schools and I
understand the point is making but then
I think that's the whole sector it's
certainly not dong can I ask you though
if Australia's four richest schools
spent more on new facilities and
renovations than the poorest 1800 yes
does that tell you that something about
the way public funds are allocated to
independent schools it is wrong it
actually tells you in essence how much
money those schools can raise I've
looked up the figures and 130th of the
capital works in independent schools are
actually funded by government 130th the
rest is actually raised by parent
contributions and by Bank lights so bear
in mind that the schools that we talking
about the elite schools get really very
little government funding
people don't understand there's a
sliding scale and the greater the will
for the parent community the less funds
schools get and so some independent
schools get very little funds in my own
school which has a so not a top-tier
school 85% of the funds to run the
budget are from parents foods and the
rest of it is the rest there's
government funds in there certainly
there's also donations there's
fund-raising there's all kinds of things
so
straightforward picture as sometimes
simplistic media coverage might make us
think well we've given it an hour
tonight I think that's a fair about
Louise kachelle has our next question if
Australia truly cares to lift education
standards and results focus must be
given to all students not just those who
are easy to teach students with
disabilities represent at least 10% of
the student population and yet they are
pushed out of schools via suspensions
bullying and exclusion being sent to
behavior schools why do these students
matter why are they treated this way and
where more this discrimination stop and
Louise can you just share with the panel
your experience well I represent a group
of students students with ADHD which is
a disability 7% of the student
population have ADHD
and they are experiencing all of these
exclusions suspensions at alarming rates
and not accessing their education at the
same rate as their peers which is
discrimination in education over in
particularly yeah it's a it's a it's a
really tricky question because I think
everybody involved in in education
teachers administration are really
focused on on on trying to deliver the
best education for all students and and
particularly students with disabilities
it's not always easy some schools do it
better than others looking at
alternative ways to deal with some of
the challenges with students with
disabilities in suspension is never
really a good solution for any student
because as somebody said before I mean
just excluding students from school
doesn't actually serve their purpose it
gives the school for whatever reason the
suspension occurred separation from the
student but it's not in the students
you've been looking at models all over
the world for solving problems right
across education systems have you seen
anywhere that is doing this getting this
particular component of the education
system right I I think all systems keep
working at it doesn't
how good they are because of because
it's the nature of people involved in
education they actually are the most
caring community caring group of people
in our in our community maybe people
don't getting the education for the
money they're getting it because they
because they love it that's true it's
definitely true when you hear an account
like that I mean do ideas bring to your
mind about how this can be done better
before ideas spring up emotions spring
up I mean it's just it's heartbreaking
to hear Louise and I know that's cheerio
technology high school where I teach it
includes so many students with a wide
variety of disabilities and that's
really challenging as Adrienne points
out a lot of the teachers who would
train their best still have a long way
to go but in many ways you know we're
kind of in the situation of making
bricks without straw a little bit I
think it's fantastic we have so much
more access now even compared to like it
was you know in the grand scheme of
things a very short amount of time ago
12 years ago ago when I started teaching
we have so much better access to
information and relevant details to
individual students learning and yet
when we think about the 150 students
that a regular high school teacher is
going to teach and many teach actually
several more than that it's an enormous
challenge and very little support is
often given at a school like Tobruk
we're really fortunate to have a great
learning support team as soon learning
support officers who often come into our
classes and provide us with that very
focused here's here's what this
particular student can really benefit
from but I know that's a benefit that
comes largely from scale and so many
schools out there that particular
student learning support officer
learning support teacher they share with
a lot of different schools that's
situation normal across New South Wales
so we have a long way to go in providing
additional support to teachers who
wanted to absolutely do the very best
for every student and just need the
knowledge and the time to implement what
actually helps
not happening in the broader school
education community one in fourth
children with ADHD are suspended from
school on average four times each 40% of
those aged four to seven years old
tiny children they're treated like
naughty children that no one wants the
teachers are not equipped they're not
trained they're not provided with Trent
there is no training for teachers
they're not trained at when they're at
University and so these students are
starting school and the message to them
is you're bad you're naughty you're out
and they're being suspended multiple
times they're going to these behavior
scores and they're being sent there and
it's not a solution it's not working
there are countries where in inclusive
education does work and is happen in
Canada Italy and those students there
with autism ADHD these sort of
neurological conditions where they have
these behaviors are able to access an
inclusive education where they are
wanted adjusted for and allowed to
access their education without being
shunned and pushed out we really
appreciate your time tonight thank you
very much
well that is please thank our wonderful
panel the Tran
John collee get Eddie whoot and your
Plymouth sick and Adrian
and hope to all of you returning up so
late on a school night
next week we're live in Melbourne
talking about the corona challenge is
Australia ready to deal with another
crisis and its impact on all of us join
us then have a very good night
[Applause]